c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche et non
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir de vacances était
un séjour j'ai eu la chance d'aller en
afrique du sud où j'ai vécu dans le parc
kruger pendant quinze jours
et j'avoue que c'est exceptionnel tous
ces animaux sauvages vraiment sauvage en
pleine liberté totalement paisible
tranquille parce qu'il n'ya pas de
chasseurs on les chasse est évidemment
uniquement qu'avec un appareil photo
donc avec un appareil photo de grosses
barca j'ai adoré c'était bien voilà les
séjours au parc kruger et je sais je
suis privilégié
mon pire souvenir de vacances c'était
quand je faisais du camping à l'époque
j'avais pas un rond et j'étais très
jeune je sais que mon frère aîné et on
avait du mal on n'entend pas n'importe
où en fait avec mes frères j'ai de
nombreux frères 1 à camper dans le sud
de l'espagne l'andalousie dans un
terrain de merde on se faisait jeter
tous les jours donc il fallait changer
de terrain à chaque fois où ont planté
la tente puis surtout on a eu du mal à
se laver on pouvait pas trop se laver
donc je me suis retrouvée au bout de
trois jours couvert de boutons ne mérite
pas la meilleure odeur sans doute en
plus non c'était pas bien c'était pas
bien n'avait pas d'argent ah oui je me
souviens d'une amour de vacances oui
bien sûr alors c'était à marbella aussi
en espagne je me rappelle de tout bois
manque de pot on avait dansé tellement
toute la soirée même si les boîtes la ba
113 aéré et souvent en plein air jeux
les ramener
à force d'avoir dansé tout ça sentait un
peu fort quoi
[Musique]